und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend jedes Kind in der Ukraine
kennt den Begriff hollodomore frei
übersetzt Mord durch Hunger gemeint ist
die von Stalin in den Jahren 1932 33
bewusst herbeigeführte Hungersnot in der
Sowjetunion bei der allein in der
Ukraine bis zu dreieinhalb Millionen
Menschen umkamen in Russland wurde
dieser Teil der Geschichte unter den
Teppich gekehrt in Deutschland schwieg
man dazu bis heute aus dem Bundestag
berichtet Winnie Häscher
am Ende verbeugt sich der neue
ukrainische Botschafter vor dem
Parlament und das Parlament applaudiert
ihm und ein bisschen wohl auch sich weil
es über Fraktionsgrenzen hinweg etwas
benennt was damals wie heute wehtut
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
hulodomorr war eine gewollte und
geplantate hungersnut um die Ukraine
gefügig zu machen um sie dem
sowjetischen System einzufahren die
Ukraine hat das nicht vergessen und doch
wir werden es nicht vergessen mit
unserem Antrag setzen wir uns mit der
brutalen Wahrheit stalinistischer Gewalt
auseinander nicht um die deutschen
Verbrechen in der Sowjetunion zu
relativieren sondern aus der
historischen Wahrheit zu lernen wir
verneigen uns vor den Opfern für uns
heißt nie wieder heute wird dürfen nicht
noch einmal schuldig werden wenn wir der
Ukraine nicht endlich mit allem helfen
was wir tun können werden wir ein
zweites Mal schuldig dass dieser
ukrainische Winter vor 90 Jahren dieser
Hunger dieses Leiden das Morden durch
Stalin in Deutschland als Völkermord
anerkannt wird dafür will das Parlament
ein Zeichen setzen doch hinter dem
Begriff vom Völkermord hinter dem
Genozid wollen sich hier nicht alle
versammeln
wenn man den Antrag liest hat man auch
den Eindruck der Gleichstellung von
Hitler und Stahli stalin war schlimm
sehr schlimm aber kein Hitler alle in
Deutschland müssen die Suche nach einem
zweiten Hitler und einem zweiten
Auschwitz aufgeben beides gab es nur
einmal die Ampel und die
unionsfraktionen stellen sich hinter die
Resolution AFD und Linke enthalten sich
wenn es um die Ukraine und Russland geht
bleibt ein Riss im deutschen Parlament
im vergangenen wie im heute
jetzt ist auch Ursula von der Leyen
offenbar der Geduldsfaden gerissen immer
wieder hatte die Chefin der
EU-Kommission mit Ungarns Regierungschef
verhandelt über den andauernden Abbau
des Rechtsstaats in seinem Land und über
EU-Gelder die in den Taschen von Orbans
Familie versickern immer wieder
beschwichtigte Viktor Orban die Europäer
und machte weiter wie bisher jetzt
könnte damit Schluss sein die
EU-Kommission empfiehlt den
Mitgliedstaaten milliardenschwere
Zahlungen an Ungarn zurückzuhalten
Isabel Schäfers aus Brüssel
so richtig hatte in Brüssel damit lange
kaum jemand gerechnet die EU-Kommission
empfiehlt rund 13,3 Milliarden Euro
einzufrieren nicht an Ungarn auszuzahlen
und setzt damit ein klares Zeichen und
ganz bisherigere Formen für mehr
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und gegen Korruption
reichen nicht wir haben geprüft ob
Ungarn genug getan hat die Antwort ist
ungern muss wirklich alle Maßnahmen
umsetzen bevor die ersten Zahlungen
fließen es gibt auch keine Teilzahlungen
für teilerfüllungen
Bedenken hat die Kommission wegen Fällen
wie diesen das Freizeitbad in der
ungarischen Stadt wurde gebaut von einem
Freund von Regierungschef Orban der
Vorwurf Vetternwirtschaft in den
ungarischen staatlichen Nachrichten ist
der Tenor ein anderer hier werden vor
allem die guten Nachrichten für Ungarn
gesendet die Fortschritte
betontlich kein Problem
wir hoffen auf einer Reihe von
Vereinbarungen mit der EU-Kommission
dies ermöglichen dass wir 2023
tatsächlich europäische Mittel
ausgezahlt bekommen
genau diese so unterschiedliche
Wahrnehmung der Lage zeigt mal wieder
Ungarns tatsächlicher Reformwille ist
womöglich begrenzt in Ungarn gibt es
quasi keine Demokratie mehr das heißt es
ist ein gutes Signal ein guter Staat
aber am Ende brauchen wir noch mehr
insbesondere bei den bei der Freiheit
der Medien letztlich müssen die
EU-Mitgliedstaaten bis zum 19 Dezember
entscheiden ob die Mittel tatsächlich
einbehalten werden sicher ist das nicht
die Tat sorgt bis heute für Entsetzen
zwei junge Polizisten wollen in einer
verregneten Januar Nacht auf einer
einsamen rheinland-pfälzischen
Landstraße ein Auto kontrollieren was
sie nicht ahnen der Fahrer ist ein
schwer bewaffneter Wilderer der um nicht
entdeckt zu werden die Polizisten
kaltblütig erschießt der Mörder bekam
heute lebenslang Christel Hass berichtet
ein großes y ein großes a die Buchstaben
stehen für Jasmin und Alexander zwei
junge Polizisten ermordet als sie ihren
Dienst taten an sie erinnert diese
kleine Gedenkstätte nahe des Tatorts
der Täter hört heute fast reglos der
Urteilsverkündung zu eiskalt habe
Andreas ess die beiden Polizisten
ermordet sagt der Richter um die
Wilderei zu vertuschen mit der er seinen
Lebensunterhalt verdiente und zwar hat
er mit zwei Schüssen einer schrotflinde
auf die Polizeibeamtin geschossen und
mit einem Schuss einer Schrotflinte und
drei Schüssen eines jagdgewehres auf den
Polizeibeamten auf dieser Landstraße bei
Kusel wollten die Polizisten einen
Kastenwagen Überprüfen der Kofferraum
war voller Welt im Wagen Andreas S mit
einem Komplizen dann Schüsse es habe die
beiden Opfer regelrecht hingerichtet so
das Gericht ich denke das Urteil kann
man generell als gerecht und
nachvollziehbar bezeichnen wie gesagt
das wird der Familie oder den beiden
Familien sicherlich helfen mit der Sache
so weit wie möglich zumindest dann
abzuschließen
auch für die Kolleginnen der Polizisten
hat sich durch die Tat vieles verändert
jeder Polizist jede Polizistin nimmt so
ein Gefühl von mir kann was schlimmes
passieren immer mit in den Dienst und
ich habe ja unmittelbar nach der Tat
auch gesagt das ist ein Albtraum wahr
geworden und durch diesen Albtraum
durchleben wir immer noch der Komplize
des Täters bleibt straffrei weil er
durch seine Aussage zur Aufklärung
beigetragen habe der Prozess ist zu Ende
was bleibt ist die Gedenkstätte nahe des
Tatorts
und hier geht's weiter mit den
Nachrichten und mit Gundula mit einer
neuen nationalen Strategie gegen
Antisemitismus und für jüdisches Leben
will die Bundesregierung Juden in
Deutschland besser vor Vorurteilen und
Hass schützen Aufklärung über jüdische
Geschichte auf allen gesellschaftlichen
Ebenen soll Anfeindungen entgegenwirken
denn es gibt immer mehr antisemitische
Straftaten Höchststand
300027 Delikte im vergangenen Jahr das
Bundeskabinett hat beschlossen
Fachkräften aus nicht EU-Staaten die
Einreise zu erleichtern und
Berufsabschlüsse aus anderen Ländern
schneller anzuerkennen einer von
mehreren neuen Ansätzen um den
branchenübergreifenden Fachkräftemangel
zu begegnen sollen zugewanderte nicht
nur in ihrem erlernten Beruf arbeiten
dürfen
der deutsche Arbeitsmarkt bleibt stabil
trotz Ukraine Krieg und Energiekrise
Saison üblich ist im November laut
Bundesagentur für Arbeit die Zahl der
Arbeitslosen leicht gesunken auf zwei
Millionen
434.000 das sind 8000 weniger als im
Vormonat aber
117.000 mehr als vor einem Jahr die
Quote bleibt bei 5,3%
. bis ins hohe Alter erfolgreich
christiane Hörbiger jetzt ist die
österreichische Schauspielerin im Alter
von 84 Jahren in Wien gestorben ihr
Debüt feierte sie mit 17 der Durchbruch
kam mit der ZDF-Serie das Erbe der
Guldenburgs vielfach ausgezeichnet wurde
sie auch mit der Goldenen Kamera für ihr
Lebenswerk
die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch
1 2 10 32 42 43 Superzahl 8
und das Wetter zum Start in den Dezember
bleibt trüben auch Morgen kaum Sonne hin
und wieder etwas Nieselregen oder
schnee-riesel bei 1° an der Oder und bis
7 Grad am Rhein auch danach viele Wolken
wenig Sonne gelegentlich etwas Regen
oder Schnee bei Temperaturen zwischen -1
und plus 6 Grad und wir geben zurück
nach Doha zur zweiten Halbzeit im Spiel
Polen gegen Argentinien ausführlich
berichtet unser heute journal Update
später um 0:30 Uhr einen schönen Abend
ihnen und tschüss
[Musik]